getting the perfect thirst trap isn't
easy and shawn mendes just proved it
it's super tricky over the weekend the
23 year old singer posted this shirtless
snap to instagram that's the grammy
winner looking buff af hiking the hills
in hollywood serving some serious face
to the camera oh my god this is a real
thing hot right it's really crazy well
sean kept it real like really real
sharing a behind the scenes look at what
it took to capture that perfect hilltop
snap
listen sean makes falling look good
thank you thank you so much but my
favorite part is john mayer's song
gravity ironically playing in the
background
and if all that weren't humble enough
sean captioned to the post quote i guess
that's what i get
i gotta say it's nice to see the
senorita singer's sillier side since
he's seemingly been in work mode for the
past few weeks making new tunes and
sharing little snippets on social media
along the way
last week sean posted that teaser clip
to instagram asking his fans in the
caption quote y'all dig this
well one sean mendez fan who loved it i
mean i think that song is really special
his ex camila cabello
i've always loved him as just i just
love him you know the singer slid into
the comments writing you're crazy
wildcat he's like one of my best friends
he's amazing shawn and camilla started
dating back in 2019.
is she your forever person like do you
talk about
an engagement one day absolutely i
really think when you know you know and
um she's been one of my best friends
since i was like 15 years old so i don't
know at the same time i know we're
really young so i don't want to jump
like insanely fast but
i think when you find your person you
feel and you know that you found your
person the two announced their split on
instagram back in november and a source
at the time told et that the breakup was
mutual adding quote they realized they
are in totally different places in their
lives at this point and it was time to
end things they're both sad about the
split but doing their best to take care
of themselves stay busy and surround
themselves by loved ones
[Music]
and that new music tease comes just a
week after sean dropped the music video
for his single it'll be okay
which naturally fans speculate is about
his breakup with camila
it's making me sick
[Music]
and while sean hasn't confirmed or
denied those fan theories back in 2020
he opened up to et about writing songs
about one another i think we're both
extremely mushy people i think we're
both super sensitive which is creates a
lot of sensitive sensitivity in our
relationship but we are songwriters so
we're constantly searching for the
sensitive topics
[Music]
okay